let's tie this up in a neat bow I'm
going to fish this question point out a
tricky thing about question three that
we didn't have a look at before and then
I'm going to give you some time to flex
your muscles on exercise one day okay
man I used to be able to say the number
one and the letter D together and keep a
straight face but I can't anymore stupid
boy bands anyway so let's have a look at
this you can see I have already
factorized and hopefully you identified
that quadratic factorization in both
cases do you agree does that look okay
yeah now you might notice as well I've
added this obscene extra amount of space
and I'm holding a different color in my
hand because what I'm about to do is to
get that common denominator and write
this in a way that just makes it easier
for my brain okay so I can see I already
have this common factor on both
denominated X minus 2 so I don't need to
multiply this guy by X minus 2 because
of this I already have it right what do
I need what is the missing term that's
going to be multiplied on the top and
the bottom yeah
X minus 1 over here and X plus 2 over
here okay I heard this looks clear to
you and the extra color just highlights
what's going on now that I've got this I
can say this guy is going to be 3 X
minus 3 watch out because this minus
sign is going to affect both of the
terms up here all right so when you go
ahead and you expand that numerator the
minus sign is going to attach to that
plus 4 just like it attaches to the 2x
okay did anyone expand it to no now no
because at the moment like we we we
factorized so that we can put these
together but then there's nothing that
tells us that indicates one more the
other might be helpful now to expand or
might be helpful now to factorize it's
kind of done its job
so I can leave it down there as it is
okay once you take care of the top that
becomes minus 2x minus 4 collected your
like terms how many X terms are left on
the top just a single X minus seven
think you're rich and then all of this
is left hanging out there all right now
just one last PostScript and it's a bit
of a potent pedantic point which is why
I didn't mention it earlier but just put
your pens down
and I want to draw your attention to
something a bit weird it doesn't really
you don't have to worry about it in this
context but you will have to worry about
it in the future especially as we go
into this next topic called functions
okay have a look at what I've written
okay I wrote here this is the question I
started with and then I wrote a series
of equals signs one two three four five
six whatever number which is to say okay
I'm gonna say that this thing is the
same as this object I finished with like
so okay and every line was equal you're
followed along with me we even tried a
different way and everything was fine
okay now this is mostly okay except
sometimes with particular values you can
break things down you can make things
stop working for example have a look at
this last expression the last one I've
written down
can you tell me because X can be equal
to anything right when X is equal to
zero what is this expression the whole
thing what's it equal to when x equals
zero when I put in if I were to
substitute x equals zero into here what
would you end up with is the answer
you'd end up with 1 right 1 divided by 0
plus 1 right that gives you 1 yeah now
look at the original expression that we
wrote the one right at the top left-hand
corner if you put in x equals 0 into
this guy what would you get now you can
throw your calculator and try this out
in fact you can put all the fractions in
all I can think but you don't even need
to right from the first thing that you
write on the numerator what's gonna
happen when your calculators tries to do
1 divided by 0 it's gonna say math error
it's gonna say forget it you're an idiot
you don't know how to use B you're not
supposed to divide by 0 you're gonna
like in the universe okay we can't
divide by 0 if you're interested in to Y
we can follow down that rabbit hole in
all the time but my point is that
putting x equals 0 into this first thing
it just kind of explodes but then should
put into this and it seems to work fine
okay now the reason why is because we
basically did this right if we didn't
say it explicitly in here but we wrote
it in there all right that's when we
multiply by X on X now if
we're equal to zero sorry let me start
again
if X were equal to any odd number like 1
or 3 or 4 this would be 4 & 4 or 3 on 3
everything would be fine
but if X were zero that's a big no-no
you can't do that right you can't just
say I'd like to multiply by X on X
because shouldn't change things right
this guy um yeah this guy misses around
with us right we're not meant to do that
and so what we were actually doing here
is we're ever so slightly changing the
question right what we started with you
weren't allowed to put x equals zero in
there this this has a name we call it
there's a restriction on this X can be
always anything you like just just don't
do this okay now when you get through
all of this simplification or you just
do this right you end up with something
at the end but this guy if you wanted to
really be the same as what you started
with you have to say hey by the way it's
not obvious it doesn't look obvious from
this at all like you should it looks
like you can put 0 into that but you
can't because this is where we came from
okay so I'm just gonna put that caution
there and I'd love you to just jot it
down at the moment like I said you won't
really have to work like the answers to
your questions the solutions will not
ever say hey by the way say this but
this will become really important you
know you'll see why I made such a big
deal at it now when we start to deal
with these guys and start to graph them
okay